Path Tracer is a progressive hardware accelerated rendering mode
that mitigates the disadvantages of real-time features
with physically correct and compromise-free global illumination,
reflection, and refraction of materials and more.
Path Tracer uses the same ray tracing architecture as other ray tracing features in Unreal Engine,
such as real-time ray tracing and GPU lightmass,
making it ideal for use in pipelines where ultra-realistic visuals are desired.
Path Tracer is not intended for real-time applications,
but rather for achieving ultra-high fidelity and realistic visual output.
Path Tracer provides the following benefits when compared to other rendering modes.
The ability to generate high-quality photorealistic renders with physically accurate results.
Minimal or no additional setup required to achieve comparable results to other offline renderers.
It reduces the feature gap of comparable real-time features.
For example, materials seen in reflections and refractions are rendered without limitations,
such as having global illumination or path trace shadows present.
It has full integration with Sequencer and Movie Render Queue to support film and TV quality render outputs,
and it has full effect support with heterogeneous volumes.
To enable Path Tracer on your project, navigate to the Project Settings and under Rendering,
select Hardware Ray Tracing and ensure that the Support Hardware Ray Tracing and Path Tracing are enabled.
After the Project Settings are configured, you can activate Path Tracer by selecting Path Tracing
from the Viewport View Mode drop-down menu.
Path Tracer will immediately begin calculating the scene.